Donald Trump in a federal court he is
the most high profile person ever to
face criminal charges under the
Espionage Act for the unlawful retention
of sensitive National Defense records
the stage is literally being set here in
Miami rows of tents outside Court as
news networks from around the world
prepare to mark this moment expect to
see many of his supporters rallying
around him one Stark poll indicates how
Republicans feel about this indictment
asked by CBS what concerns the most
about the Trump charges just 12 said it
was the fact that the documents posed a
national security risk 76 percent of
Republicans asked said their biggest
concern was that the indictment was
politically motivated of all the
chapters in the Donald Trump story this
is compelling the waters ahead truly
Uncharted there is no precedent for this
president